my audience knows if you've been
following the show for some time that I
avoid being overly optimistic or
pessimistic about any particular
election and I always make clear that no
matter what the polls tell us today the
only thing we can control is whether we
vote and we should always vote in that
context in the last week there are a
bunch of races that are going very much
the wrong direction there is what I
think can accurately be called a
democratic collapse happening in many
races and a possible Red Wave Rising now
at the start of the week I told you
zooming out the forecasts for the House
and Senate have worsened for Democrats
and they have improved for Republicans
but where can we see this at the
individual race level
and I'm going to tell you up front that
it these are this is ugly these are very
ugly numbers that I'm about to show you
here look at some of these races Florida
Senate incumbent Marco Rubio is
challenged by Val demings demings is a
great candidate who had one of the best
debate performances of all the debates
that we covered what at one point was a
Rubio lead in the region of five two
three four five six has now become a
seven and a half point lead for Marco
Rubio very quickly Getting Out Of Reach
for Val demings moving on to DeSantis
versus Charlie Crist also in Florida
Charlie Crist mopping the floor with
DeSantis who visibly malfunctioned on
Monday night we played the clips we
showed you all of it what at one point
was a five six seven point lead for
DeSantis has now swelled
uh to an 11 point average lead for
DeSantis with as much as a 14-point lead
in some of these individual polls this
is quickly Getting Out Of Reach Florida
quickly looking like it will fall to the
most extreme elements of the Republican
Party
or stay in their hands I think better
said in Georgia again talking about the
best Democratic performances this cycle
Stacey Abrams was one of them facing off
against incumbent Republican Governor
Brian Kemp what had been as you can see
if we go back actually I don't oh I do
have the older data what had been many
polls in the Kemp plus two four two five
one area
has now become Kemp 6 Plus 6.7 and
almost seven point lead for Brian Kemp
not totally Out Of Reach but
increasingly difficult for Democratic
Challenger Stacey Abrams I don't tell
you this to demoralize you know there's
this horrible thing that happens where
no matter what I say about polling
someone's mad if I say look the polls
are looking terrible for Democrats
people say oh David you're demoralizing
Democrats so they won't go vote
and if I say oh look the polls are
looking good for Democrats people write
to me they say David you're giving
people false confidence they're going to
think they don't need to vote folks I
tell you what is going on and I also
tell you how I believe we should react
and no matter what the polls say we
should react by voting but more of these
races here is a race where the Democrat
is still winning but by a dramatically
smaller margin than it was at one point
Dixon versus Whitmer Gretchen Whitmer is
the current Democratic governor of
Michigan Tudor Dixon is the Republican
Maga Challenger if you look you see that
even as late as August 24th Whitmer was
up by 16 points by the middle of
September that was down to an
eight-point lead the lead was halved
and now it is a three-point lead for the
Democrat Gretchen Whitmer Michigan
governorship is now in play for
Republicans it's sickening if you look
at Ohio Vance versus Ryan Tim Ryan the
Democratic Challenger not Challenger the
Democratic candidate JD Vance the
Republican candidate JD Vance by sucking
up ferociously to Donald Trump he was
able to secure an endorsement from
Donald Trump if you look at that race
what at one point uh
was a actually this this one actually
hasn't changed that much it's a relevant
one to include because it's important
but it actually has not changed that
much advances plus two and that's more
or less where it has been more or less
where it has been
um but it is
um potentially another seat that will
fall to Republicans
um Georgia Senate Walker versus Warnock
Rafael warnock's lead is now half a
point and this one is really really
sickening Herschel Walker can barely
speak and he can't explain his positions
on any issue he's completely incoherent
Warnock not a great debate performance
but clearly the competent candidate if
you look back at the history here
Warnock was up four to five points in
Late July still up four to five points
in August but that lead started to
shrink shrink shrink to the point of a
tie
briefly during the Walker Scandal
Warnock opened up a five-point lead it's
basically a tie Herschel Walker who
cannot speak and cannot think may
replace Raphael Warnock as a senator
from Georgia and then Texas governor
Greg Abbott the incumbent versus Beto
O'Rourke this at one point was a sort of
closer race if you look at late June it
was Abbott plus six if you look at
um there was a sort of brief point where
the liege was smaller I don't remember
exactly where it was oh it was it was
actually last year it was five this has
now become a more than eight point lead
for the incumbent Greg Abbott which in
Texas will be quite difficult for a
Democrat to overcome doesn't mean we
stay home
what else do you have to do on that day
we should all vote and we should fight
every race but there is a serious
concern right now that a red wave is
coming and it's a combination of a few
things most importantly most importantly
this is
the effect of Roe v Wade being
overturned which help Democrats
fading too soon being supplanted by
economic concerns and despite
essentially Full Employment and almost
unanimously positive economic indicators
rhetoric on inflation
reigning Supreme in the minds of many
voters and it is shaping up to be
potentially disastrous for Democrats so
what do we do we vote we vote we vote we
vote one of the most anticipated debates
in the 2022 election cycle was last
night it was quack television Dr Mehmet
Oz against Democratic Pennsylvania
Lieutenant Governor John fetterman they
are vying to be the next senator from
Pennsylvania now I am not going to
sugarcoat this for anybody and I didn't
during yesterday's much watched live
stream John fetterman suffered a stroke
some months ago he is recovering and has
been cleared by his doctors to say you
can serve as Senator he is not
struggling cognitively in the sense of
memory
logic critical thinking but fetterman is
struggling significantly when it comes
to
um speaking and translating thought into
speech it's really sad to see and
what is horrifying is that the
completely unqualified
delusional and incompetent Mehmet Oz
may become a senator
because John fetterman had a stroke
and didn't perform particularly well
last night it was difficult to watch I'm
putting politics aside here for a second
I feel terribly for John fetterman
public figure in the middle of a
campaign has a stroke running for an
important office and now visibly
struggles to speak needed closed
captioning during yesterday's debate
um in order to better understand the
subject matter having having trouble
with auditory processing
um I hope for the absolute best for
fetterman's recovery and it was a very
difficult debate to watch last night by
the way fetterman was not a particularly
good debater I mean fetterman was the
best candidate in the Democratic primary
but even at the Democratic primary
debates he wasn't the best debater let's
look at a few clips from last night the
most disturbing clip was when Mehmet Oz
said that local political leaders should
be the ones making decisions along with
patients and doctors about abortion no
they shouldn't it should be doctors and
patients but here is Oz with a very
extreme statement there should not be
involvement from the federal government
and how States decide their abortion
decisions as a physician I've been in
the room when there's some difficult
conversations happening I don't want the
federal government involved with that at
all I want women doctors local political
leaders letting the Democracy that's
always allowed our nation to thrive to
put the best ideas forward so why do we
need politicians in the room why is it
better if they're local this idea of let
the states decide died when there really
aren't differences like let me give you
an example when it comes to gun safety
as an example Bernie Sanders is correct
that gun ownership in Vermont is a very
different thing socio-culturally than it
is in I don't know North Carolina
and so
regardless of your views I can
understand why one would say well
because gun ownership in Vermont is a
different thing than in North Carolina
maybe there should be a different
conversation happening in each state it
doesn't mean we don't have gun safety
regulations or that I think we shouldn't
have them but it's at least plausible
when it comes to abortion it's
fundamentally about this is a medical
procedure and this is a procedure in
which you shouldn't have politicians in
the middle why is it better to have a
local
of you know a governor or a mayor
telling women what they can't do rather
than a senator in DC either way it's bad
and this is a completely outrageous and
extreme position here is just a clip
just to really sum up the difference in
the positions between Mehmet Oz and John
fetterman on this issue all I want women
doctors local political leaders letting
the Democracy that's always allowed our
nation to thrive to put the best ideas
forward so states can decide for
themselves contrast that with my
opponent John fetterman but if you
believe that the choice for abortion
belongs between you and your doctor
that's what I fight for it's it's that
that's it's that simple it's that simple
and Oz's position of course has been
cobbled together in trying to basically
focus group the best possible thing to
say exceptions but not this and no
federal involvement but let local it's a
mess and it's outrageous and it's
extreme the fetterman position is the
correct position now John fetterman did
comment on his stroke and he had the
following to say about it so Mania
here's a man that spent more than 20
million dollars of his own money to try
to buy that seat
I'm also having to talk about something
called the Oz rule that if he's on TV
he's lying he did that during his career
on his TV show he's done that during his
campaign about lying about our record
here and he's also lying probably during
this debate and let's also talk about
the elephant in the room I had a stroke
he's never let me forget that
and I might miss some words during this
debate mush two words together but it
knocked me down but I'm going to keep
coming back up and this campaign is all
about to me is about fighting for
everyone in Pennsylvania that ever got
that needs to get back up and fighting
for all forgotten communities all across
Pennsylvania that also got knocked down
that needs to keep Pennsylvania yeah so
as you can see
um
it takes a lot of courage to do what
fetterman did last night
it it's he's in the middle of a recovery
from a stroke and uh he brought it up
and it was really something to see and
also quite difficult to watch the issue
of the quack cures promoted by Mehmet Oz
on his program came up yesterday and
listened very carefully to the exact
language that Oz uses and you will very
quickly see why he's choosing such
narrow language Mr Oz you have built a
lucrative career around medicine but
you've been criticized even by some
fellow Physicians for promoting quote
unproven ill-advised and at times
potentially dangerous treatments what is
your response to that you have 60
seconds
did you or your company make a profit
from promoting those products I never
sold weight loss products as as
described in those commercials it's a
it's a television show like this is a
television show so people can run
commercials on the shows and that's a
perfectly appropriate and very
transparent process
I never consider the language there okay
I never sold
weight loss products
as described in John fetterman's
commercials
okay that is extraordinarily narrow
language he provided a platform
for those products
it made the show profitable
he was promoting green coffee extract as
a magical weight loss cure that is not
evidence-based he was promoting
raspberry ketones as the quote number
one miracle in a bottle to burn your fat
that is not evidence-based he promoted
guests who say Homeopathy works
uncritically and I know some people in
my audience get mad about this it
doesn't work guys I'm sorry I know
people email me every time there are no
active ingredients in Homeopathy there
are no measurable active ingredients it
does not work it has been widely studied
oh but David big Pharma won't allow
studies guys Homeopathy has been widely
studied
it doesn't work and Oz promoted it so
extraordinarily narrow language there Oz
also promoting medication supposedly for
colds uh the way to get rid of a cold is
to wait five to seven days okay no
matter what you take during those five
to seven days right coffee enema which
is dangerous by the way uh uh you know
fried plantains
um baths with uh
whatever you know coconut oil bath
five to seven days later the cold will
be gone and to attribute it to all of
these different supposed cold cures
doesn't actually make any sense so
bottom line the question with this race
is what happens with the polling what
happens with the polling at this point
in time because going into yesterday's
debate the polling is what it is right
now fetterman plus 1.3
fetterman plus 1.3 and is if you take a
look you will see that fetterman had a
nearly nine point lead in early August
and that lead was only six at the
beginning of September and that lead was
only four towards the end of September
and that lead is now 1.3 how much of an
impact can a single debate have on a
race like this particularly when one
candidate is visibly struggling with his
speech as a result of the stroke that he
had I don't have the answer but we'll
find out in the next seven to ten days
and listen the election's only two weeks
away and then we'll know a lot more
early voting has broken records already
two weeks before election day but I have
to tell you it is not obvious to me what
this means so let's start with the news
and then we'll work backwards CBS
reporting early voting turnout breaking
records two weeks before election day
with seven I'm sorry with 15 days to go
to election day early voting is underway
in 34 states in DC
more than seven and a half million
people have already voted either in
person or by mail some states have
already smashed early voting records set
in the presidential election of 2020.
but uh voting has not been without
incident we talked about the people with
guns and tactical gear in Arizona
etc etc etc the most important question
about this early voting record and we
we're talking about this I was talking
about this in another context recently
is
which side is voting in record numbers
and is that a signal about what might
happen in this election or are both
sides just voting in record numbers
and maybe the most important question is
whether the early voting records are
related to enthusiasm or it's merely
that more people are voting early and
fewer people will vote on the day of but
that it doesn't actually represent more
enthusiasm for participating in this
particular election is it not reflective
of higher overall turnout and I don't
think we had that answer yet and the the
thought process is as follows
in 2020 many states in the context of
the covet pandemic expanded early and
mail-in voting
many people took advantage of that but
many did not it was the first time for
some of those expansions in many states
now that it is more known we may simply
be seeing a shift
from people waiting to vote on Election
Day to choosing to vote early either in
person or by mail
if that is the case
it doesn't necessarily mean voter
turnout will be particularly high no
matter what you think is going on and no
matter what is going on just vote just
vote the headline may be great news
potentially a pacifier the most
important takeaway is no matter when you
vote your vote matters and we want
everyone to show up and vote let's have
a representative democracy that is as
representative of as high a percentage
of the population as possible and that
means every single one of us should vote
uh reminder reminder reminder
our YouTube channel has a million and a
half subscribers but we had 4.3 million
people watch our videos last month this
leaves nearly 3 million people who are
watching the content but aren't
subscribed I heard after I mentioned
this earlier this week from a dozen or
so people who said you know David I
watch all your Clips I'm not a
subscriber on YouTube because YouTube
Just feeds me the clips anyway and I
understand that help us by hitting the
Subscribe button on YouTube it's totally
free it's one of the most important
signals to YouTube
hey promote this guy's content more it
costs nothing and there's almost 3
million of you out there who can do this
for us youtube.com the davidpackman show
will take a quick break and be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show is a viewer a
listener an audience supported program
and I would love for you to sign up and
show your support at joinpakman.com this
is the membership program the much
discussed and much maligned oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad indeed indeed Alex
thank you we do a daily bonus show and
offer a commercial free audio and video
stream to all of our members every
single day
sign up at joinpakman.com we're down to
the wire on Election 22 you can use the
coupon code big
voting22 big voting 22 to get a healthy
discount off of the cost of a membership
speaking of the 2022 election
Rolling Stone has an incredible report
out about the Trump plan it's an active
plan to try to steal the 2022 election
now you might be saying well steal it
steal it in what way because Republicans
may do quite well in the 2022 election
Rolling Stone reports that Donald Trump
has quote convened a series of in-person
meetings and conference calls to discuss
laying the groundwork to challenge the
2022 midterm election results during
these meetings and these conference
calls quote pro-trump groups attorneys
Republican party activists and Maga
diehards often discuss the type of
scorched Earth legal tactics they could
deploy now this is for elections they
don't win specifically understand that
this is not about let's come together it
sounds so stupid because it's so
unbelievable let's come to let's do
something good for democracy let's come
together to ensure that the rightful
winner as determined by the will of the
people actually wins every single
election
that's my Tucker Carlson laugh
that's not what they want that's not
what they want this is for elections
they don't win let's figure out what
sort of tactics we can use to try to get
some of these anyway they came close in
2020 and they're not giving up one route
that they reportedly planned to take
says Rolling Stone is to do the exact
same thing on Election night that Trump
tried in those early hours of the 2020
election which is you come out and you
say there has been fraud or fraud As
Trump says
uh I won this is embarrassing we're
winning this election and remember
frankly we did win this election those
chilling words at 2 A.M were you didn't
win anything what are you talking about
frankly we did win this election that is
one tool that they are looking to employ
maybe with more favorable district
courts secretaries of State Governors
Etc
the report from Rolling Stone is that
Trump is very focused on Pennsylvania
including Oz V fetterman we already
talked extensively about that race
earlier and the internal dynamics of
that race why would Trump care so much
about Pennsylvania it should be obvious
at this point 2024
is the reason why in 2024 Pennsylvania
could determine who is the next
president of the United States and
certainly having your guy in as a
senator who could potentially object to
the counting of the electoral votes in
the uh in January of 2025 is useful also
having a governor in Doug mastriano who
chooses the Secretary of State who
oversees the election in 2024 would be
very very useful I'm increasingly
wondering what if any connection there
is between the armed Intimidators
outside of Arizona ballot boxes and this
Trump movement I don't know I'm just
asking the question and what you have to
understand is that at the end of the day
their proposals make no sense
they don't have that many options left
but the cheat and steal look at some of
the things they're proposing a National
Abortion ban that's completely unpopular
at a time when Roe v Wade is as popular
as it has been over a 50-year period now
you're going to say National Abortion
ban that doesn't make sense so instead
you go to cheating and stealing doing
nothing about gun violence and actually
proposing more guns in more places
despite constant mass shootings that
doesn't make a lot of sense so then you
go to well we can cheat and we can steal
looking at gutting and cutting Social
Security and Medicare
when older voters are demographically
they're bread and butter that doesn't
make sense so you figure out ways to
cheat and steal
if they can get away with it they're
going to try or rather I should say
they're going to try and they may be
able to get away with it and if you want
to get a sense of the level of delusion
here
let's go to Jon Stewart's incredible
interview that is going to be published
in full very very soon Jon Stewart has a
uh he has a pretty good new program I
have to tell you the thing he did in the
middle there after The Daily Show it
wasn't so good this new thing is very
very good and Jon Stewart has done some
extraordinary interviews recently uh Jon
Stewart interviewed a Mark bernovich
he's the Attorney General of Arizona and
he interviewed him about all sorts of
different claims of so-called election
irregularities fraud Etc
and this is just a little bit of a
preview the full interview is going to
be out over the weekend I believe take a
look at this and as good as a job as Jon
Stewart does focus on the lack of
serious
thinking that Mark burnovich displays
here right now we have about I think
almost 20 criminal cases related to the
2020 election out of four million votes
yeah no I I'm talking in fact John but
the reality is is there are millions of
people not only in Arizona but people
throughout this country that think the
election is stolen there's people that
believe in angels but that doesn't mean
you launch an investigation that Angels
change ballots that's a really important
thing
because all these Mega people that I
interview and they say we we just want
to know for sure we just want a forensic
audit which they can never Define we
want this that and the other thing so
that we can really be sure
the level of Investigation
needs to correlate to the level of
evidence for irregularities and again
when this guy says we we have 20
instances that we're investigating here
20 cases out of 4 million votes it
doesn't warrant the degree of spending
and resource allocation that they have
been doing that bit of a tautology
when you have a former president
spreading rumors yeah to his supporters
for instance Trump can say
74 000 mail-in ballots received that
were never male magically appearing
ballots 168
000 fraudulent ballots printed on
illegal paper 36
000 ballots illegally cast by
non-citizens now the truth is none of
that was real when it first came out the
Cyber ninja said Joe Biden won Arizona
and then they got a lot of pushback when
they started hedging and Hauling and
then next thing you know people are like
well bernovich needs to do something
about it and then it was like the hot
man you've responded by doing things
about it you what I've done is Ed you're
still investigating we've run it we've
run a lot of the stuff to ground and
when you get it to ground will you come
out and say Donald J Trump is wrong
the election in Arizona was fair not
stolen and not fraudulent I I I've
always been a straight shooter and once
no all once all the facts and evidence
for John John come on man I'm telling
you you have found no evidence that the
election in Arizona was fraudulent or
stolen from Donald Trump Donald Trump
lost Arizona period I've said that from
the very beginning there have been
isolated incidences thus far that we've
identified yes and we are Prosecuting
yes we still have some active
investigations going on but people can
draw their own conclusions no no it's
how can you draw your own conclusions
about facts no no people cannot draw
their own conclusions that's the point
of the law yeah it is the law is that
you have facts right and you have
fiction right the fact is the election
in Arizona was well run not fraudulent
and not stolen for from Donald Trump
according to even your investigation I
have never said why is it so hard to
just say yes to that I just I guess
because I've spent my entire most of my
career as a prosecutor and we still have
some ongoing cases but he could say up
to this point I have found no legitimacy
to any of the claims so in your mind you
still feel like after all this you're
gonna discover no a concerted effort to
steal the election from Donald Trump and
and that it was fraudulent is that what
you're saying no that's not what I'm
saying so why can't you say the election
in 2020 was not stolen or fraudulent I
will tell you this as I said this is
blowing my voice yeah it is mind-blowing
and this is not some random Kook I mean
he's a kook but what I mean is it's the
Attorney General of Arizona
and it should be it it's very scary that
even he can't just say
it's over
it's over there was nothing here one
other thought
one of the lines they continue to use is
we need to investigate because a lot of
people aren't confident
that it was all on the up and up
but the reason that those people aren't
confident is because of Lies told to
them by those who want an investigation
right Trump goes we can't trust the
results I really want Arizona
uh ballot dumps toilet ballots uh
ballots and sandwiches ballots with
barbecue sauce that is not not native to
the United States you know all this
crazy stuff
so people go wow we really need to
investigate then Trump goes look the
people want an investigation yes but
they want it because of the lies you've
told them and it becomes circular uh
this is going to be a really good
interview I look forward to seeing the
full thing um and you can see the clip I
played today on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well Sarah
Palin is really having a tough one it
turns out a lot of people in Alaska just
don't like her Sarah Palin you might
remember uh former mayor of Wasilla
former governor of Alaska although she
quit that job former running mate to the
late Senator John McCain in 2008 she was
the vice presidential running mate she
is now running for the House of
Representatives
um she was on the phone with uh real
America's voice which I guess is Steve
Bannon this is the War Room Steve Bannon
show and she is very triggered that her
fellow Republican Lisa murkowski from
Alaska
is supporting Palin's Democratic
opponent and you really do love to see
it it's quite a rare thing here she is
complaining to Steve ballon Bannon they
won't help me even Republican Lisa
murkowski is supporting a Democrat this
is a delight my friends the big
the big thing is to say Lisa murkowski's
race or Senator even though she's not a
republican uh she just she actually is
the other day not voting for me in my
race she's not voting for the Republican
party she's actually literally
announcing that she's voting for the
Democrat in my congressional race so
that I don't win that's what I'm up
against yeah well listen it is a delight
it's rare for a sitting Republican to
back any Democrat and in particular when
you're a sitting Republican as is
murkowski who is up for re-election in
two weeks and she's supporting the
Democrat in that race Mary paltola Lisa
murkowski cannot stand Sarah Palin
that's what's going on Palin quit
halfway through her term as Governor of
Alaska it rubbed tons of alaskans the
wrong way they don't like a quitter Lisa
murkowski doesn't like a quitter and
Lisa murkowski I've been listening it's
sort of like the the Susan Collins thing
right
Lisa murkowski will sometimes say
slightly more sane things than many
other Republicans at the end of the day
she mostly still votes with Republicans
but okay she doesn't like Palin and
she's not voting for Palin and Palin
seems to be losing very very badly
there's a new article from the
bipartisan report from a few weeks ago
and uh it has the the latest polling
data and the key paragraph is this one
um peltola starts in round one because
they have ranked Choice voting voting in
Alaska peltola starts in round one
meaning initial results with almost a
majority the progression of the results
puts peltola against baggage for a final
tabulation unlike the results from the
special election that gave peltola her
currently unfolding stint in Congress
when Palin made it to the end in these
results paltola finished with 54 of the
support baggage at 45 eliminating
baggage before the final round instead
of Palin still show Republicans losing
with peltola nabbing 56 percent of
support there evidently wasn't enough
crossover among the Republicans
supporters on either side and this is
the signal this is the data on which it
is believed that Sarah Palin is just not
consolidating enough support
um to actually win this and 65 of
alaskans Express negative feelings about
Sarah Palin so it is not looking good I
believe this is the end of are Palin's
political career if indeed she loses
this election let's hope that she does
we have viewers in Alaska Alaska a
unique state in a lot of ways culturally
geographically Etc I believe Palin will
lose all the evidences that she will
lose and hopefully that will be the end
in terms of hearing from Sarah Palin and
her political career let's hope looking
forward to 2024.
more and more Republicans are saying
Donald Trump's not going to be the
Republican nominee now I'm able to find
no data that points that way but let's
take it a step at a time as I like to do
and start with the claims that are being
made there's an article on the hill
from this morning growing number of
Republicans say Trump won't be the
Republican nominee
former speaker Paul Ryan
former Florida Governor Jeb Bush former
vice president Mike Pence in recent days
each indicated they'd rather see someone
else on the ballot in the next
presidential election
some of the most outspoken figures like
Ryan Bush and congresswoman Liz Cheney
are no longer standard bearers of the
party which has been taken over by Trump
exactly but they still carry large
megaphones there are concerns about
another term candidacy combined with
polls showing many voters are ready to
move on illustrate how Trump's viability
as a candidate could shape how the
primary comes into Focus
former house Speaker Newt Gingrich said
some people like Trump and some people
don't like Trump he's the most dominant
single figure in the party and that's a
fact we played the clip a few days ago
of Mike Pence saying well there might be
somebody else I'd prefer more when he
was asked about supporting Trump in 24
Pence may be planning to run himself
uh Paul Ryan speaking about 24 says I
think Trump's unelectability will be
palpable by then we all know he will
lose or let me put it this way we all
know he's much more likely to lose the
White House than anybody else running
for president on us our side of the
aisle so why would we want to go with
that
and then you could find other people Joe
O'Day the Republican Senate candidate in
Colorado says I don't think Trump should
run again Mitch McConnell has kind of
played Coy with it uh Lindsey Graham
says we have a pretty good chance uh
with with Trump running but pretty good
chance isn't necessarily the best thing
so the most important question is how
are they going to stop him if he runs
they can barely stand up to him now when
he's not even running for anything do we
really imagine them standing up to Trump
after he announces not really do we
imagine them standing up to Trump after
he survives longer than a few other
candidates who start to drop out in the
support consolidates around Trump the
way we saw it in 2016. I don't know that
I see it and most importantly look at
the polling data that we have 2024
presidential nomination we have polling
from uh from this month there's a New
York Times Siena poll from this month
there's a Harris poll from this month in
the New York Times Siena poll Trump is
leading by 23.
with DeSantis at 26 so it's Trump 49
DeSantis 26. in the Harris poll Trump is
leading by 38. that doesn't really look
like Republican voters are ready to
abandon Trump if you look at the betting
markets the betting markets those are
asking the question not who do you
support in 24 but who do you believe
will win it's basically a dead heat
between DeSantis and Trump so the most
optimistic data we can find is that the
betting markets at predictit.org say
it's basically a toss-up but then you
also look at some of the other latest
polling and this is polling on
hypothetical matchups now this is who
could win who could win in 2024 there
there is an argument maybe for someone
other than Trump because you look at
recent polling Emerson College says if
the race were today Biden beats Trump by
three Yahoo news if the race is today
Biden beats Trump by two
um so the best case would be there isn't
great polling for Trump winning in a
rematch but it is very early and there's
almost 15 12 12 to 14 undecided when you
pull people today
part of me wants Trump to run
because there's a real chance that
DeSantis would fare better against the
eventual Democratic nominee at the same
time crazy things can happen and anybody
can end up winning as we have learned
and as we have seen so it's really up to
Republicans I don't have advice for them
I think Trump is uh vulnerable if he is
the nominee
but maybe that's a reason that we want
to see him run if we're looking from the
left but the most important question to
the Republicans and it's up to them to
figure it out I'm not giving them advice
if you really don't want Trump to run or
you don't want him to be the nominee
what can you actually do to dissuade
Republican voters from supporting him
because as of right now there's clear
support behind only one candidate and
that's Trump there's a smaller but still
statistically significant amount of
support behind DeSantis no one else is
polling greater than five or six percent
I know we're two years away but I don't
understand how they stop Trump if Trump
wants it let me know your thoughts
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
former Trump advisor Stephen Bannon
recently sentenced to jail for four
months but free pending and appeal is
now openly threatening Dr fauci and his
family with being quote hunted if indeed
Republicans take control of at least the
house in November uh in the 2022
midterms Bannon at this point is an
overtly dangerous and disgusting figure
in American politics truly sick here is
Steve Bannon fauci what is wrong with
our country that they want to go after
fauci they are obsessed and here is what
Bannon had to say uh on the 8th of
November when we destroy the Democratic
prize of national political institution
and really end the regime by the way the
use of the word regime here uh totally
propagandistic and inaccurate the hunted
become the hunters the hunted become the
hunters so uh and you heard Natalie at
the top the whole fauci family is going
to be welcome to the investigation
why fauci's kids why are you going to
investigate fauci's kit what I mean
putting fauci aside for a second his
whole family the entire family remember
war room was taken off Twitter because
of comments I made about wait for it
Christopher Wray and Anthony fauci that
their day was coming they but that has
nothing to do with fauci took us down
they took the War Room account I've
never been on Twitter they took the worm
account on Twitter paybacks across the
board and all that big move wow
retribution they're gonna hunt people as
retribution this guy is truly disgusting
I mean think about it being mad at Dr
fauci because threatening him got you
banned from Twitter first of all what
does that even have to do with Dr fauci
as question number one
but it's like a blame the messenger sort
of thing it's the most base and
disgusting thing and understand that you
know what why is everybody's why are
they on the right so mad at Dr fauci
it starts with something
that is typical of cults
fauci committed the mortal sin to the
Maga right-wing cult
he did not kiss the behind of the orange
emperor
he said hey you know what
we shouldn't inject bleach
that's not a good idea hey you know what
we don't have evidence that
hydroxychloroquin works to treat covet
it's anti-science
it's overtly pro-ignorance pro-hate and
it's also contrarian for the sake of
being contrarian and there's you know
we've talked a lot on the program about
conspiratorial thinking we've talked a
lot on the program about cults and cult
members oftentimes the Cults promulgate
conspiracy theories and sometimes in
addition to the brainwashing and all the
different stuff
there's a desire to be contrarian simply
for the sake of being contrarian
conservatives and Trump supporters
should be mad at Steve Bannon Bannon
fleeced Maga people way more than fauci
did remember that uh Bannon
fleeced Trump supporters out of millions
of dollars and is in the middle of
criminal prosecution for it remember the
whole build the wall thing give us the
money and then we'll build a wall
which of course they weren't doing and
they didn't and now there's there's a a
prosecution happening
the Maga people should be angry with Ben
and not with fauci who gave the best
medical advice based on what we knew at
the time at all points in time during
the pandemic
but no they want to hunt Anthony fauci
and this is absolutely a form of
stochastic terrorism meaning with a
large enough audience if Bannon
continues shining a spotlight on fauci
and his family hunted fauci and his
family hunted people in the audience can
get the idea maybe I should be the one
doing the hunting and sadly
Dr fauci needs full-time security
because that is indeed a real threat a
trump lawyer Alina Haba
is now making the new claim that Nancy
Pelosi orchestrated the January 6 2021
Trump riots at the U.S Capitol
how is that possible how is it possible
that that's what she did well here she
is Alina Haba explaining it herself
and there are two basic fundamental
important claims that underlie this idea
they've both been debunked and we're
going to get to them but understand that
they don't even know what to say anymore
and so now it's forget about Trump
didn't incite the riots Nancy Pelosi
orchestrated them don't need it get them
in place he was concerned himself he
said let's get extra uh military we will
give you people to come in and to make
sure that the capital is safe no no I
don't want it well now we see why Eric
we see why because it was orchestrated
because she said this is her moment this
is her moment no it's not your moment
okay so there's two claims there and
these are claims that they've repeated
many times the first claim is
Trump asked for 10 000 National Guard
troops which would have prevented the
riots that's claim one okay this is how
we actually figure stuff out okay the
first claim is Trump says I asked for
ten thousand troops they didn't give
them to me the second claim that's being
made is Nancy Pelosi
rejected the 10 000 troops coming to
Washington DC to prevent the riots so
two claims Trump requested Nancy Pelosi
rejected neither one of them is true the
first one is the Trump claim okay
there is no evidence that Trump made
that request now if you want to be
endlessly uh skeptical
you can always say is it possible Trump
requested the troops and the request was
thrown in the trash in order for there
to be no evidence you can always do that
but the point here is
there is no evidence
uh written
Telecommunications
people on the other end of the request
saying yeah I got we got that request
from the Trump White House for the
National Guard troops PolitiFact has
explored this and has determined that it
is false they have found no such
evidence
the second claim is that Nancy Pelosi
rejected the troops Sean Hannity has
been saying it for a very long time and
so have others again there is no
evidence that Nancy Pelosi Chuck Schumer
or anyone else rejected the request for
the ten thousand or sometimes it's
twenty thousand troops that are
mentioned now of course if there's no
evidence that the request was ever made
there's no request to reject either and
that's another layer to this thing
that's important to mention I would love
it if Alina Haba made some of these
claims under oath
I don't think that's going to happen and
remember that Donald Trump's TV lawyers
and his court lawyers tend to be
different people we heard from Michael
Cohen about how that works and I don't
expect to actually see Alina have him
make any of these claims under oath but
every single one of these claims has
been soundly rejected and or there is
simply no evidence for it whatsoever one
way or the other because it doesn't
appear that such a request was ever made
they'll keep telling the LIE
and we have to keep reminding them
there's just no evidence you're just
saying that you're making that up we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P
here is a question about trans youth and
surgery puberty blockers
etc etc and it's targeted at me based on
something a viewer thinks I was I guess
deliberately doing the other day take a
listen
David I just watched uh
covering of the census Christ debate uh
when it got to the part about uh
uh transitioning uh transgender kids I
noticed you were pretty quiet uh where
are you on uh kids under 18 and uh you
know teenagers 13 14 15 taking uh
puberty blockers and uh uh taking other
transitioning hormones and uh
um in some cases uh
uh you know the medical uh surge surgery
that does it yeah
um like uh taking out their breasts uh
genitals and um
uh did you support it as a gender
affirming care or do you think that uh
uh if you're under a certain age it
should not be uh should not be given to
kids okay so listen I was not being
deliberately quiet for any particular
reason my view on this issue of trans
youth puberty blockers gender affirming
surgery trans teens five to seven year
olds versus 12 to 14
Etc my view is there are so many
different situations that need to be
dealt with
differently
and
I am not an expert in that and so I know
that it has become really in for every
podcast host and streamer and whatever
to take hard and fast positions on every
aspect of this if and when are puberty
blockers okay and what about the surgery
and then claims about oh hospitals are
trying to convince people to transition
and all of this stuff that's not backed
by any actual kind of evidence that it's
taking place my view on this is what I
currently believe
the overall
position of experts medical experts to
be not religious clergy not Republican
or Democratic politicians and that is as
follows
you need a multi-pronged approach when
it comes to
trans youth people under 18.
there are medical aspects to this there
are social aspects to this there are
educational aspects to this there are
mental health aspects to this there are
policy related questions that have to be
answered
I don't pretend to have all the answers
and I believe that a lot of the specific
elements of this are still being studied
what I can tell you for sure is that
we're not going to get to the best
outcome for the trans youth by allowing
Republicans to set the terms of the
debate
to ban all sorts of things again as if
they know better than doctors which
we're familiar with them when it comes
to abortion and on and on and on now I
will also say the left
should not dismiss parts of the
conversation that they don't like I'm
going to give you an example here okay
here's an example of something that I've
seen some on the left dismiss
it should be explored
weather
when a 15 year old says I believe that I
am in the wrong body when it comes to
sex I was born biologically male but I
feel that I am a woman
it should not be dismissed
that maybe that is a reflection of what
is happening in society
for someone who is struggling with
something but it may not necessarily be
that they were born into the wrong body
and what I mean by that is
it should it should be explored whether
there are deeper components to what is
going on and because of what is
taking more attention in the media right
now
some folks are being drawn to that now I
know some of you will say David are you
saying there shouldn't be gender
affirming no no no there should be
absolutely everything but it should also
be a conversation that is being had and
by the way it is had when people want to
transition there are conversations with
mental health professionals the right
likes to pretend someone says after 15
years of living as a boy they say I'm a
girl and two days later they're having
surgery that's not happening that's not
happening but the point here is
all aspects of this should be considered
all aspects of this should be considered
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about the
supposed trend of quiet quitting quiet
quitting I have a lot to say about this
and I've read quite a bit about it many
of you have emailed me saying David you
should discuss this we will today
the world's dirtiest man has died in
Iran at age 94 what does that mean the
world's dirtiest man I will tell you and
the Nazi holding a Kanye is Right sign
on the 405 freeway in California has
been identified and the situation is
very quickly getting very very ugly I
want you to sign up for a membership at
joinpakman.com and then you will get
instant access to the bonus show thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well you don't have to be me
you can just listen to the bonus show
and that's good enough joinpakman.com is
the place to sign up you can use the
coupon code big voting22 to get a
sizable discount and I look very much
forward to seeing you then
foreign